in this video we're going to do a few
examples finding domains of functions so
let's say that we have the function f of
x
is equal to
x plus 5
over x minus 2. what is going to be the
domain of this function pause this video
and try to figure that out
all right now let's do it together now
the domain is the set of all x values
that if we input it into this function
we're going to get a legitimate output
we're going to get a legitimate f of x
and so what's a situation where we would
not get a legitimate f of x
well if we input an x value that makes
this denominator equal to zero then
we're going to divide by zero and that's
going to be undefined and so we could
say the domain
the domain
here is all
real
values
of x
such
that x minus 2 does not equal 0.
now typically people would not want to
just see that such that x minus 2 does
not equal 0. and so we can simplify this
a little bit so that we just have an x
on the left hand side so if we add 2 to
both sides of this we would get actually
let me just do that let me add 2 to both
sides so x minus 2 not equaling 0 is the
same thing as x
not equaling 2. and you could have done
that in your head as well if you wanted
to keep x minus 2 from being 0 x just
can't be equal to 2. and so typically
people would say that the domain here is
all real values of x such that x does
not equal 2.
let's do another example
let's say that we're told that g of x
is equal to the principal root of x
minus seven
what's the domain in this situation
what's the domain of g of x pause the
video and try to figure that out
well we could say the domain
the domain is going to be all
real
values
of x
such
that are we going to have to put any
constraints on this
well when does a principal root function
break down
well if we tried to find the principal
root the square root of a negative
number
well that would then break down and so x
minus seven whatever we have under the
radical here needs to be greater than or
equal to zero so such that x minus seven
needs to be greater than or equal to
zero now another way to say that if we
add 7 to both sides of that that would
be saying that x needs to be greater
than or equal to 7. so let me just write
it that way so such that x is greater
than or equal to 7. so all i did is i
said all right where could this thing
break down well if i get x values where
this thing is negative we're in trouble
so x
needs to be
greater x minus 7 whatever we have in
this under the radical needs to be
greater than or equal to zero and so if
you say that x minus seven needs to be
greater than or equal to zero you add
seven to both sides you get x needs to
be greater than or equal to positive
seven
let's do one last example let's say
we're told that h of x
is equal to x minus 5 squared what's the
domain here
so let me write this down the domain
is all real
values
of x
now are we going to have to constrain
this a little bit
well is there anything that would cause
this to not evaluate to a defined value
well we can square any value you to give
me any real number and if i square it
i'm just going to get another real
number and so x minus 5 can be equal to
anything and so x couldn't be equal to
anything so here the domain is all real
values of x we didn't have to constrain
it in any way like we did the other two
the other two when you deal with
something in a denominator that could be
equal to zero then you got to make sure
that that doesn't happen because that
would get you an undefined value
and similarly for a radical you can't
take the square root of a negative and
so we would once again have to constrain
on that